What I want to do
in this video is
analyze why it makes sense
for two companies that
make up a duopoly to coordinate.
To get into an agreement,
which may or may not be legal--
probably would be illegal--
and restrict quantity.
But also think about why
there's a strong incentive
for either or both
of the parties
to cheat their agreement
and produce more quantity
than they agreed to produce.
So let's say that both of
our players in our duopoly--
and this would actually apply
to an oligopoly generally,
but the analysis would be a
little bit more difficult if we
had more than two
players-- but let's say
each player has an identical--
they're identical companies.
And they both have a
marginal cost curve
that looks something like that.
So they both have an
individual marginal cost
curve that looks like that.
And they both have an
average total cost curve
that looks something like this.
And they are identical.
So I'll just draw it once.
This is the marginal
cost and average total
cost for both firms.
Now let's think about what it
would look like for the market.
Well, one way to
think about it--
pick an arbitrary marginal cost.
So for one firm, what
can they produce,
or what quantity will they
be at that marginal cost?
Well, they'll be
at this quantity
for that marginal cost.
But if you have two firms
that are just like that,
they could have twice
as much quantity
to be at that point
in marginal cost.
So two firms will be over there.
And if you picked
this marginal cost,
one firm would
produce that quantity
to be right at
that marginal cost,
for that next incremental good.
But two firms could
produce two, especially
if they have the exact
same cost structure.
So what you're going
to have is you're
essentially adding
this curve to itself
in the horizontal direction.
So if you look at the marginal
cost curve for both firms
together, you're
essentially going
to get a curve that is twice
is fat as the marginal cost
curve for one firm.
So it will look
something like this.
And I'll do it in yellow.
So it will look
something like that.
So that is the marginal
cost for the market, where
the market in this example
is both of these firms.
And that will also be true
for the average total cost.
If at this price--
or actually, I
should say, if the average
total cost is up here
for one firm-- that
means that they
are producing this quantity.
But two firms together could
produce twice the quantity
of that average total cost.
So two firms would
produce twice.
And so what you're going to have
is an average total cost curve
that is twice as fat as
the average total cost
curve for one firm, if
you talk about the market.
So the market's average
total cost curve
is going to look
something like this.
It's going to be twice as fat.
It's the exact same logic.
It's going to look
something like that.
So that is the average total
cost curve for the market.
So, so far, the convention
that I've ended up using
is orange for an
individual firm,
and then this dotted yellow
line for the market as a whole.
Now let's think about
what a good equilibrium--
or what the right
price should be
if they were able to
coordinate together.
If they were to essentially
combine their firms and almost
behave like a monopoly.
And to think about
that, we're going
to have to draw a demand curve.
So let me draw the
market demand curve.
Let's say the
market demand curve
looks something like that.
It's really big, so
it's hard for me.
And we'll assume
that this is a line.
So it's not-- well,
that's pretty good.
So this is the
market demand curve.
So if both of these firms
operated together, if they--
I drew the market demand curve.
I also want to draw the
market marginal revenue curve.
Now remember, we're going to
assume that both of these firms
are acting together.
If they perfectly coordinate,
they can join their capacities
and act essentially
like a monopoly.
So if they did act
like a monopoly,
their marginal
revenue curve would
be twice the slope of
this market demand curve.
So it would hit the horizontal
axis right over there.
And so it would look
something like this.
So this right over here is the
market marginal revenue curve.
So if they were to
behave like a monopoly,
you could view this dotted line
as their marginal cost curve.
This would be their
average total cost.
And now this is their
marginal revenue.
If they were to
behave as a monopoly,
what would be the
optimal quantity?
Well, it would be right there,
right where marginal revenue is
equal to marginal cost.
Before that, they
would keep wanting
to produce because
marginal revenue is
higher than marginal cost.
And then after that, they
don't want to produce,
because marginal cost is
higher than marginal revenue,
and they're going to
take economic losses
on each of those
incremental units.
And so this is the quantity
that they would produce.
And the price they would
get for that-- they just
have to go to the
market demand curve--
they would get this
price right over here.
Let's say they would get
that price right over there.
And the actual-- their average
total cost per unit-- once
again, we have to go
to the market here.
It's this dotted
line right over here.
That is their average
total cost per unit.
So their average
economic profit per unit
is going to be their
revenue per unit,
minus their average
total cost per unit.
So this height is their
economic profit per unit.
And if we multiply that times
the total number of units,
you would get their
total economic profit
if they coordinate perfectly,
essentially behaving
like a monopoly.
And let's just say for
argument that this height
right over here-- let's
say that that is 10.
And let's say that
this quantity that they
would want to produce
as a monopolist is 50.
So what is the total
economic profit here?
Well, their total
economic profit is 500.
Total economic profit if
they coordinate is 500.
And so they see this, and
they say, look, why don't we
agree to each produce
exactly half of this,
and we would split
the economic profit.
And to see that, let's
just say one firm says, OK.
They both decide that
they're going to produce 25.
They're going to get
this price for it
up here, which was
the market price.
They're going to get
that price for it,
and their costs are right here.
Now we're going on
each individual firm.
And that makes sense,
because this cost is just
twice as far away as this cost.
And the dotted line
yellow average total cost
for the market is just a
fatter version, twice as fat
as the orange line.
And so each firm will make
this much economic profit
per unit, times 25 units.
And so each firm would
make this orange area
in terms of economic profit,
or half of the entire 500,
or 250 per firm.
Now let's think about why
there is an incentive for one
or both of the firms to cheat.
Let's say one firm
in particular--
so the other firm
holds at 25 units.
But the other firm says,
hey, I like this price.
I'm already making
economic profit.
Let me produce 10 more units.
So the other firm says, I'm
not going to produce 25.
I'm going to produce 35 units.
And if that guy
produces 35 units,
and the other firm in the
market-- the other duopolist,
I guess we could say it--
continues to produce at 25,
then the total market production
is now going to be 60.
Now what is the total
economic profit?
So we can go up the demand
curve right over there.
That's the new price.
That right over there
is the new price.
The cost per unit is
this right over here,
and then the number of units
that they're producing is 60.
So the new economic
profit is this area,
in this bluish purplish
color that I just drew.
And even visually this is true--
looks like the demand curve
and the average total cost curve
have gotten closer together.
So let's say that this
height right over here is 8.
And it's going to be $8 of
economic profit per unit,
times 60 units.
So if they cheat--
let's talk about
the cheating circumstance.
This was coordinate, now let's
think about if they cheat.
Now we have 60 units
for the whole market
times $8 of economic
profit per unit.
You're going to have total
economic profit of 480.
Your total economic
profit went down.
And that makes sense,
because now as a market,
you're producing
beyond the point
where marginal revenue is
equal to marginal cost.
Now marginal cost as a market
is higher than marginal revenue.
And so all of this
is essentially,
you're creating economic
loss because each
of these incremental
units as a market--
The cost is higher
than the revenue,
and you have an economic loss.
And so that's why your total
economic profit as a market
went down from 500 to 480.
But how much is this
character going to be making?
The one that decided to cheat?
Well, he now has 35 units.
He's producing 35
units, and he's
getting an economic
profit of $8 per unit.
So he gets this entire
area right over here.
So let's multiply 35 times 8.
I'll do it right over here.
35 times 8.
5 times 8 is 40, 3 times
8 is 24, plus 4 is 280.
So now the cheating
firm, Cheat, has
$280 of economic
profit in this period.
And then the honest firm, or the
fair firm-- what they're both
doing might be illegal by even
attempting to coordinate--
the non-cheater, I guess
I could call them--
the non-cheater
will have the rest.
The non-cheater is going
to have the balance
of the economic profit.
And the total economic
profit was 480.
The cheater's getting 280.
The non-cheater is
only going to get 200.
So the cheater
definitely benefited
by increasing quantity
past that optimal one.
He went from 250 to 280.
So it made sense for him.
It reduced the total
economic profit,
and it really hurt the
non-cheat right over there.